Cheers
so yeah I'm hurry my talks called
normalizing design for better quality
CSS it's a real mouthful my thread it's
also got a second sort of title
rationalizing designs they're really
sort of subtly different but quite
significantly sir so the next sort of 40
minutes I'm going to cover the kind of
stuff I've done for us to innovate years
in my day job which bit it boils down to
saying nerdy designers a lot of the time
as CSS developers we spend building
people's PS DS when they're not designed
them ourselves but we spend most of our
time implementing them and a lot of my
time is spent actually not implementing
stuff and telling designers no you can't
have this as a result I've kind of got a
third title for this talk which is why
designers here at me
I think after working so closely with
designers for quite a few years they
have stopped here to me quite as much
but it's still a real interesting
dynamic I have with design teams because
I do push back on a lot of things that
they want and initially when you join a
new team when I joined my team when I
was a move to Sky it was a really
awkward kind of hurdle we had to get
over where I spent a lot of the time
telling these really talented designers
that I like what you've done but you
know I can't build that we shouldn't
build that and the reason I've chosen to
talk about this today is as Nicole
mentioned all the speakers who are here
weren't chosen weren't asked to speak we
were we everyone submitted a proposal
and I really wanted to be here so I
submitted this because I thought it
might something that generate a lot of
discussion it's potential bit
controversial so yeah I want to open
some discussion up and if any wants to
share anything after all I mean we'll
chat over lunch or over a beer but in
the meantime if we put anything on
Twitter I'd live to see people's
opinions on the kind of stuff I'm about
to talk about I know that a lot of
people don't take too well to it
particularly designers I don't if
they're any sort of designers in the in
the room but I'm yeah I'd really like to
open up discussions see whatever annex
of the kind of stuff that that I do and
I think people should do more off and
any disagreements are really welcome
because I want to hear sort of the the
opposite
the coin so if anyone has heard of
anything I've done before it's probably
through CSS wizardry which is an mi
really here now I'm stuck with that and
I'm kind of I I've done lots of speaking
open source stuff I love writing about
sort of CSS architecture for last few
years and I'm a quite an exciting point
at the mint because I just kind of quit
my day job and I want to do CS it was at
least a full-time pastor so that's so
taking this kind of idea of
rationalizing designs and taking up to
other companies so I'm currently in the
process of leaving sky now I believe
you've probably heard of sky you've
heard of sky over here right it's a real
big sort of UK sort of a multimedia sort
of organization I've been there for two
and a half years as a sort of a senior
UI developer and kind of the only UI
developer so I was plunked between a
team of software engineers who are super
clever at what they do and a bunch of
designers who were really talented
really creative really clever smart guys
and I've sort of sat in between these
two roles and acting like a bridge
between engineering and design it's
really fun role to have it also means
that I've had to deal a lot with that
with people and people's opinions and
sort of keeping people happy and the
kind of work I've done at Sky as being
fairly big sites slice it take months
and months to build heavily traffic
sites science that have sort of dozens
of engineer's working on them and the
thing is with these sites they start off
fairly big but they're only getting
bigger there's one site that I built
two-and-a-half years ago I've started
building two and a half years ago and
right now they'll be people in the
office working on that site today
it's a codebase that's lasted two and a
half years and it's going to keep
growing
and it's really important to to be able
to manage that it's all well and good
building a big website but if you get
lumbered with a badly built big website
you can have a ton a happy team so it's
been my job at Sky to keep and front-end
as small as I possibly can anyone who
worked product genuine work product or
in-house or for like a start or anything
like that we've got your own code base
that you work with every day right so
quite a few of you actually could you
imagine having to go to that job every
day if the code base was a nightmare
I worked at places where that's the case
and if your day job if every day you're
working on code that you've grown to
resent that's not a nice place to be
so I might drop to keep code bases as
small as possible as soon as possible
but first and foremost and most
importantly maintainable one thing I
learned quite early on at Skye was the
easiest way to keep a code base maintain
is just to keep it small it stands to
reason that the smaller your code base
is the less problems you'll have you
know less things are out to go wrong
statistically less can go wrong because
there's less of it the less you have to
look after just keeping things small is
the simplest single where to keep
something maintainable and easiest where
to keep it small instead of a white less
stuff and this is where I come back to
telling designers no I think it's really
important even if you've got a business
led decision that we as developers
designers programmers still sort of dig
our feet and if we think something's a
bad idea or dig our heels in and say no
to things or what of the time I've spent
a this guy has been saying no to design
features design treatments that I think
might look nice but won't really benefit
the codebase what we've got to remember
is that we're delivering websites and
websites are built on curd we're not
delivering designs not delivering prints
if we're not delivering PSD s that's
part of the process what we're giving
users is curd basis you know the users
don't know that they didn't need to know
about the curd behind it but that's what
we're building and we need to take care
of that first and foremost it's really
important I fire a quick disclaimer in
here though because I'm gonna talk sort
of for the rest of this for the rest of
this talk a little like it's me versus
that and I really don't want that to
come across I don't like I'm patronizing
designers I don't know sound like I'm
looking down on them it's certainly not
the case so this talk is an anti design
and this talk is about keeping designers
and developers and the business and
users happy I've got a really good
professional and working relationship
with my design team from the design team
at sky
they do some fantastic work they're very
clever guys and we've got a mutual
respect so this talk is an anti design
I'm not saying designs a bad thing at
all another thing to know is this the
kind of stuff I'm talking about it won't
work on every site and
we shouldn't the kind of sights I'm
talking about a bigger website which I
refer to a sort of a UI based I think
about the Facebook's the Google+ apps
that people keep returning to that
people spend a long time on things that
are inherently big but need to be
consistent
this kind of stuff wouldn't be really
appropriate for a photographer's
portfolio or a single paid marketing
site so yeah list of apps to talk about
might not be appropriate for the kind of
stuff you are working on or all the kind
of projects you might have worked on
previously and you might just disagree
with me like I said and we've got a
hashtag if you do just think I'm talking
out to the rubbish I'd live to know
because then I have worked fairly soft
solar for the last two and a half years
and this is something I found has really
worked for me
and I've never had opposition from other
developers because there haven't been
any I find opposition from designers so
I'd really like to get your opinions if
you have any yeah if you disagree I'd
love to know why or what potential other
ways of working that you you guys sort
of work to and a lot of the stuff I've
done with sky has been based around
making compromises now compromises a
really negative sounding word people
think of it as a bad thing but
compromise is actually really really
good
because what compromise does is it keeps
more than one person happy compromises
like the opposite of selfish it's been
really important for me that I've
established a good working relationship
and personal sort of friendships with
that with the design team we have
massive respectful one of those jobs I
know that I need to get out of their way
and let them do their thing but there
now understand that I'm a developer I
think differently to how a subjective
and creative person would think I think
very objectively one thing it's really
important is I never just sin so I kind
of made it sound like a doob I always
discuss everything but I'm thinking
everything I want to do and explain why
this is really important for two reasons
it allows this collaboration to happen
it allows them to fire back their
opinions but it also allows them to
understand why I think how I do and it
allows them to start thinking that way
as well so I'm going to open up the
discussion for alternatives
to preamp the kind of things I would see
as sticking point yet we collaborate to
reach ideals now I'm sky and I'm aware
that several larger companies still do
have quite a slow moving process and
that's probably a business rather than a
dev problem you know the business want
to see PS DS so we get those and then we
take them into the brows and we build
them bigger companies people that talk
about often enough but bigger companies
do move a lot slower and it's harder to
have a complete design in the browser
culture and we don't have one at sky
what we have is a phrase that someone
coined recently and I can't remember who
it was and decided in the browser I
don't if you heard that iPhone only
knows who who who came up with that if
you could tweet that maybe brilliant I'd
love to attribute them we decide in the
browser and I do that alongside
designers because a PSD for it might
look nice you've got no idea how or if
that can work in real life so we have
this process where yeah they'll come to
me with a Photoshop file and I'll start
building and I'll say well hey look look
at this I don't think this is very good
because you know it's a bit half key so
what can we change so we decide in the
browser but importantly no means no if a
designer says to me look no you're not
changing this we have to have this I
will argue my case and I'll discuss why
I think it's a bad idea but their
opinions are just as valid as mine and
if they're adamant that they want
something to stay in want something to
to remain as is I will respect that and
if no means no if they don't want me to
change the thing then there are some
times when I weren't a lot of the
discussions are half with designs at sky
based on what our rounds of like cheesy
one-liners I'm a sucker for a sound bite
this is something I put in an article a
few years ago I can't remember which
article it was but people still quote me
on this a PSD is a clue and not a
contract so yeah a designer will come to
me with a PSD there's no guarantee that
I'm going to build exactly what they've
put down people see is this contractual
obligation this is the first a shop file
therefore this is what we're going to do
and that's a really bad way of thinking
it's very stubborn way of thinking it's
very very detrimental to the entire
process because if you draw a line at
PSD stage you've got the entire
rest of the project where you stuck with
a decision that you made far too early
on I like up like I said we need to
decide in the browser it's far too early
on to commit to anything when it's just
pixels in Photoshop
what PSD will do is this is the clue
aspect gives me an idea of what the
designer wants it gives me an idea of
the kind of feel they want the site to
have it'll tell me what brand treatments
what colors are used you know what can
I've turned the page will set it can
give you a really good cysteine and it
might be very complete and very polished
PSD it might look like it might look
like it could be a complete design but
you should see there's no more than
clues and and kind of yes steers and
pointers to where the design should be
headed under quiet calls if the design
atmosphere which i think is a really
really nice term it's not in third
design it's how the design feels and you
can glean a lot from a PSD just just in
terms of the design atmosphere tick is
clues and hints as to what the designer
want and not as a gospel agreement as to
what they shall get another thing I find
myself saying to the team a lot is um
it's doable but you know I weren't or
it's doable but I don't want to or I
shouldn't we find that we can build
almost anything and we're all good
developers and there aren't many
problems we come across that we can't
yeah we can't build something but
doesn't mean we should just cuz we can't
find a solution doesn't mean that we
always should use it
basically we pride myself on writing
reams and reams of CSS to build crazy
designs that some would come up with if
you ever got a PSD of a print designer
right I used to get really proud I was
like oh I could build up and I'd have
like a style sheet this long to build
one header and I used to really love
that you think I am so good at my job
look I've made this look exactly like
the PSD and assumed why actually wasn't
even that soon I'll admit it was a years
before I realized this is very very
naive this is a very silly way of
working because there's so much more to
building a front-end than just
replicating a PSD
you shouldn't have a right curd that's
terrible just a satisfier design that
could have been changed like I said
where we're building products are based
on curd we should never have curd suffer
for the sake of something superficial
especially working on a product that you
after for several years the codebase is
what you work with day-in day-out
don't sort of sacrifice the quality of
that code base for something that could
have been avoided current leads mentor
just because you can doesn't mean you
should and I've spelled doesn't wrong
that's embarrassing so this pearl of
wisdom is from Jurassic Park of all
films right that the bitly URL is a
scene in Jurassic Park where they're
discussing the fact that sure we can
bring dinosaurs back but is that a good
idea should we do it it's actually a
really good scene it's quite a metaphor
for a lot of other things and in their
case bringing dinosaurs back wasn't too
wise so yeah just because I can
or because you can doesn't always mean
you should avoid problems don't try and
just show off and write complex
convoluted code just to satisfy a design
team think about the the end user can
you write something that's fast satisfy
other developers make sure that and
inherit your code and they just sort of
look at it blank Fair's wondering why on
earth you did something just because you
can doesn't mean you should
performance is a really big thing for me
I tend to say this - designers quite a
lot of sky they're really into sort of
you know retina stuff retina looked real
nice and you always notice an on retina
experience but it's a performance
overhead it's a hit to your site speed
you've always got to think about things
a little wider than well it looks nice
isn't gonna how nice it looked if it
takes 20 seconds to get onto someone's
device it's kind of a misguided effort
users do live an appreciate good design
they interact more with beautifully
designed things nicely designed things
are typically easier to use if you work
on a product or an app that you want
people to engage with and use over and
over again a nice UI is very important
but studies have shown time and time
again that users will leave before they
even get to see that UI if your site is
slow they won't stay around to see how
nice you've designed it they will
disappear so you've got to think about
how fast you can get something that
looks almost as good on to that users
device it's something I'd like to work
to performance first
stuff like mobile first and content
first a really good noble sort of
schools of thought but I like to go back
even further and start performance first
because performance first will benefit
everyone it's a matter of feeling of a
fiber connection on a brand-new shiny
mutton book or you're going through a
tree internal honor on a blackberry
performance first will benefit everyone
and this is something we've moved
towards the sky I'm really proud of the
designers that we've done some great
work together we've sort of managed to
form this good working relationship
where I had a designer come to me a
couple of weeks ago it's like a hurry
I've designed this but I was thinking if
we get rid of that we can save a couple
of requests and I thought that's really
cool to have a designer because we've
got a very traditional split we have
designers me and engineers so we still
have a very tiered approach but the fact
that I'm getting designers to think
about HTTP requests while they're
tinkering in first a shop that's really
good news for the product it's really
good news for the codebase it's really
good news for the team so I've kind of
got our designers thinking performance
first everything that design will have a
performance impact and how can we
mitigate and lessen that something I
will readily admit I completely made up
is the 80/20 rule again these were
conversations I have with the design
team at Sky and any designers I work
with typically an 80/20 rule loosely
sort of states that um if we can achieve
80% of a design in 20% of the curd then
we should always take that option if it
was pick some really easy numbers if
we've got a design and it would take a
hundred lines to code it perfectly to
get a hundred percent of that design it
would take a hundred lines of code if I
could build 80% of that design something
that's almost the same in 20 lines of
code I will pick that on every time
because like I said before the easiest
way to keep a code base maintained was
to keep it small the easiest way to keep
it small it's just a trim things out
anything superficial anything that
doesn't really really matter if we can
get rid of it then we're gonna we're
gonna start seeing benefits across the
board if you scale this way of thinking
across a site that's two and a half
years old and you trim everything you
can for two and a half years the amount
of savings are huge all these things
sound like micro optimizer
I got a friend called Jamie Mears and a
fantastic JavaScript engineer and he
says if you look after the bit the bikes
will look after themselves so a lot of
micro optimizations will add up to over
a project that spans years they all add
up to sizeable servings this is
something that designers actually said
to me
my boss is a lovely guy I met in five
years ago he worked an agency together
five years ago Rob Farnell really clever
guy but we've got such a friendship that
he kind of really takes the piss out of
me at work and he tells me this all the
time if I said to him I'm not building
that he'll say like well I thought you
could couldn't are you not up to it can
you not do this and it really annoys me
I know he's I know he's winding me up
and but it's kind of the same thing as
before just because I come doesn't mean
I should um but telling a team of
designers but I won't build something
often makes me look like a bad developer
they often questioned why unemployed
what why am i there to do this job when
they know they could build it again it
was so much more to being a front-end
developer than just pixel perfect
matching PS DS a front-end developer has
to think about the quality of occurred
base the the product as a whole and the
rest of the team and you'd never judge a
builder's ability or his worth on his
ability to lay bricks because that's
looking far too far to sort of fine you
judge a builder's abilities on how well
you can create a big strong structure
that will last for hundreds of years
to measure a front-end developers worth
on his or her ability to some match
designs in the browser is really
something I even close minded way of
looking at things
there's far much more to it than that so
you've got to look at the bigger picture
that's why you know we think performance
first that's why we think about how we
can scale this website how we can keep
it maintained about how we can keep it
nice to work with I can guarantee that
if my day job was just seeing how while
I could match designs
this site is two-and-a-half years old
we'd want to scrap that by now and two
and a half years isn't in a long time
and this site is going to go on
indefinitely it could end up being five
years old and you know five years worth
of just matching PS DS pixel for pixel
would lead to a terribly complex
convoluted and nasty codebase one thing
I've noticed particularly among the
might of engineering friends people far
cleverer than I am is the better you get
at writing code the less you want to
write so it's happened to me I used to
live right in terms of CSS to perfectly
replicate a PSD the batter I've got at
my job the more I've learned the more
I've realized that I don't want to lie
anymore code I own occurred this I don't
want to get any bigger I want to do
everything I can to keep it small to
keep it nice to you to work with I've
got what why I resent writing any code I
feel I could have avoided any time I
write something sort of bespoke that I
know will never get reused it's kind of
a hit and it's going to happen of course
it's going to happen you couldn't have
two page headers you know there's
certain things you will only have one of
I hear having to write anything bespoke
because anything bespoke is like it's
like it's dead wet and later it will
happen that avoid all costs I would like
to recycle things if I see anything like
I think I could have borrowed from
elsewhere but I've missed an opportunity
that's time to go back and refactor it's
some people sort of accuse me of her
premature abstraction which is kind of
ferreting I see the point it's like a
rule of thumb don't abstract until
you've used something two times and I
don't do that or cover this in a second
and I was try and write everything to be
reusable from the outset because
anything you can reuse is free of charge
and free of charge is a really important
thing in growing a curd base free of
charge means it already exists but it
costs you nothing to use it again
anything you can get free of charge is
really really nice it's a nice thing for
a code base to have the way to write
less code to the simplest ways are to
normalize and abstract these are food to
to computer science terms normalization
usually deals with data sets and and
trimming down repetition in those an
abstraction deals with them sort of
taking design patterns and putting them
elsewhere in like a reusable deep purple
state that's a normalization
it's not spotting repetition so Nicole
I'd give a really good talk it's quite a
while ago now I imagine called our CSS
best practices are killing us and and
this dealt with normalization and and
the idea that if there's a lot of things
repeated across a design then there
should be sort of gathered together
spotting repetitions are really useful
skill to have allows you to gather these
things and normalize them but more
important than that is opting the
potential for repetition so someone
might have used you know the same color
in ten different places you can abstract
that out but what if they've used
similar colors in ten different places
can we distill that down into different
one and this is things that are these
are things that Nicole's dealt with
quite in-depth so if we take this
example we've got a header footer on a
content div they've all got really
similar padding values they're only two
pickles apart will the user notice that
the footers two pixels smaller than the
header I don't think they will so why
why have that departure can we distill
this down into just one number can we
make them all twenty pixels and I'm
pretty sure we come so this is
normalization and this is a really timid
example if you if you take this school
of four and apply it to a full front end
you will find lots of potential for
repetition you can normalize out so
normalization is the start but their
neck needs do is abstract this we need
to take these things and wrap them up we
need to decouple them from their initial
purposes there are little use cases we
take these normalizations put them in
little bundles that we can reuse
anywhere that are completely agnostic to
the Dom or to whatever they were
initially spawn from so if we look at
this we've now normalized this design
pattern we've we've shared that 20
pixels across these three things but
it's still very tightly coupled we can't
reuse that anywhere else without adding
another selector to that list so we've
kind of got half way that we've
normalized this really simple design
pattern but now we need to put it to
work and only to abstract it the first
thing we'll do is pop it in a variable
and of course using SAS because
well there's no other alternative as far
as I'm concerned let's not start off a
war about that one on Twitter there
please so yeah she's popping something
in a variable pre processes are really
good at helping you use abstractions
they're built for that very purpose to
avoid you repeating things so the
simplest single step we can take is just
dropping this 20 pixel into a variable
take that step further we can drop it
into abstracted clusters so we have a
class of box this didn't tie itself to
any type of content this is this is now
a free thing to reuse this is an
abstraction that we can play it wherever
we want
we'll use a solid class and drop into
markup which is my preferred way of
working but you know if you don't like
that then we can use the we can use the
silent class and use extend this is a
way of taking those normalizations and
now moving them completely away from
where we originally found them into
something totally reusable it's all
decoupled and now it becomes free of
charge and you know these are really
timid examples these are just well they
are just our examples and you can spot
these yourself and and we can put these
to work for us this is a real simple use
case but there are hundreds or infinite
amounts more that you can spot for
yourself and it's doing stuff like this
if - to keep code bases where I've
worked nice and small so I mentioned
that sort of get accused of premature
abstraction I make sure I got the right
word there so like I mentioned before a
lot of people will say don't abstract
something until you've used it twice
that's a lot of the engineers at sky
have sprints where they've just got
refactoring work to do and I hate
refactoring I think it's so dull so what
I do is I have strapped everything up
front everything I write I like to think
is going to be reusable it may never get
reused but for the circ of it why not
just do the job properly the first time
round so whenever I get accused of
premature abstraction I kind of prefer
to call it prepared abstraction if
you're going to spend a complete sprint
refactoring your curd or I'll just do my
own thing and not have that of boring
stiffly because I've already done my job
as well as I come from the outset
doing it that way from the outset does
mean that there will be things that will
never get reused so there is some sort
of there is a hit upfront but if like me
you don't enjoy refactoring kurd then
this is probably the best way to go
another sort of cheesy soundbite I use
with with designers is that they're
called rule sets for a reason and again
this isn't really true it's just like a
metaphor so designers will come up with
really sort of subjective and a nice
looking creative designs with free rent
I believe that you know you shouldn't
bog designers down too much with
overhead and and sort of comic strips
because that will limit what they can do
and so I like to do it sky so design
what you think is the best solution and
then we all work together to flash out
into a proper production solution that's
what I said them is they're called rule
sets for a reason so what I do is armed
whatever you've designed I now as a
developer with my sort of developer hat
on I have to distill down into rules but
the good thing there is consistent user
interfaces are all based around rules
anyway yeah and I sort of I mentioned
sort of sites like our Facebook and
Google+
these are big sites you want users to
interact with for a long amount of time
if everything's consistent it kind of
gives them a little more faith in that
product in that site they can trust it
more because they know what to expect so
good consistent user interface is best
run rules anyway so if we can set these
subjective designs and distillers down
into rules that we stick to the codebase
are going to stay a lot smaller it's
been easy to manage but also the user
gets a better experience the user can
have more faith in a product or service
because it always responds and looks and
behaves the same this is something I
actually drew about two or three weeks
ago in a meeting and I thought would
snap at first wait for this talk Rob the
guy who were mentioned earlier who takes
a Nick out of me we were discussing a
component I don't know which one it was
it I think it was just any generic
component we're building a component
library at Sky and in the middle line
you see that comes up straight out
a straight line that has enough you know
that is the longest one that is the
ideal lifespan of a component that you
don't touch if you don't touch like if
you stick to the rules that is its happy
a little lifespan and nothing ever
changes you'd have to worry about
anything any departure from that becomes
a fork in the curd so let's say we've
got a component and on one page it needs
to be a little bigger in something
that's a fork in the curd on another
page or for whatever reason you might
want to have a different font I don't
know why you'd do that but yeah that
could be the case or there might be an
error state in which you know it becomes
red all these modifications all these
variations of a component or extra
commitments every of a breakage of any
rule is a commitment what if we change
the the topmost version how will that
impact anything else because CSS
inherits and shares so much we have to
know that if we change one thing we need
to know how it will affect any of the
six or seven others every fork in the
curd is more overhead and the more you
can reduce those Forks the better of
course if something does need to be read
in an arrow state then we can live with
that we can have one fork but every
single thought that tries to be
introduced every kind of rule anyone
wants to break needs to be really
carefully considered I think if you're
gonna if you're going to come up with
rules all the from we've had previously
as a we'd come up with rules and the
business would be like we're gonna have
this button a little bigger so you can
it's really easy to do but now we've got
to have one different type of button
just to satisfy that request is that
really worth it and it's it's really
interesting place to be when you have to
sort of tell designers they can't have
this until the business they can't have
that and you're in the middle of it all
and it all comes back to this sort of
sorting out your relationships with the
people you work with and rules are
really really nice where to get people
to agree to things up front
and like I said I will break rules if I
need to if it's a really valid reason we
can work to that and we can work around
that so I've got some I got some quick
examples now when I submitted the
proposal for this talk I was like that
sounds quite interesting then about ten
minutes later I was like
how am I gonna write like a 40 minute
talk out of this and then I started
writing it I realize it's like this this
should be like a half-day workshop so
I'm gonna blitz through some stuff
fairly quickly I've tried to have this
above a theoretical talk than a heavy
soft curd led talk and one of my
favorite UI and design based rules when
I would share happily with everyone and
I will recommend to everyone is a rule
that you can set when the first of four
lines of your new project and any new
project you start you'll probably do
something like this you will decide on
the best font size and the best line
height this is a real fundamental
decision that hopefully you'd write it a
little more like this but what it all
comes down to is the fact that you've
chosen a base font size of 16 pixels and
a baseline height of 24 pixels
24 is a very very important number the
first decision you make about a build
can underpin the piece of the sizing and
the either build of your entire project
that 24 pixels now becomes our base
spacing unit and this is something I've
done on every single site I've built
every single site I've built for us two
and a bit years and it's never let me
down yet so I'm really quite confident
about this and how it works
this underpins the sky back on the site
that I keep referencing that took sort
of two and a half years so I've put this
into practice and its really worked
quite nicely our base spacing unit so
I'm probably fairly confident you've all
seen code like this before
and initially nothing looks too too bad
with that but I I cringe when I see code
like this because well 38 pixels is a
really specific number to be on such a
loose selector why why 38 where's that
coming from
a code base that you can't rationalize
that you can't trust is is bad news
because I see that there's 38 pixels a
margin on my h1 I don't touch that that
number sounds so specific that there
must be a reason for it somewhere so I
won't change that and most developers
weren't so you'll add another class and
you'll add more code to try and get
around this 38 that's inexplicable this
isn't very say incured this is hard to
rationalize it's hard to make sense of
and if you got this in a big codebase
it becomes really hard to work with so
my solution did the best spacing unit is
give every block level element the same
initial margin bottom the link at the
bottom there is a that I'm covering is
so article I wrote about this this base
spacing unit can be used to sort out
your entire site spacing and the nice
thing is because 24 pixels in our base
line height as soon as we apply that as
the margin bottom we get perfect
vertical rhythm for free so we get a
nice reading experience completely for
free here and this is this is like a
rational seer number that has a reason
behind it applied to very loose
selectors now if we want our page title
to be double what we can do that quite
easily as a rule we can break because we
can rationalize where that number came
from in the first place but it's not
about margin bottoms either sir I wrote
an article called the island object
which is better a more abstract way of
thing like a box so now we pad that
Island object by 24 pixels that number
has a purpose we know where it came from
because it underpins our entire UI but
if we want a smaller box an eyelet for
example we can just have that number
which leads us on to the next thing a
really nice ruler I haven't managed to
write this up yeah I just haven't at the
time I real to write an article on this
and called UI sizing scales so we've got
this 24 pixels that underpins our our
men sort of spacing so we can do things
like this we can spin off any variations
of a component that we might need just
by having this BAM inspired naming
convention here we can have things we
can double them we can quadruple them so
for example yeah here we've got there 24
pixels again but the tiny version six
pixels and these rules that we can stick
to we can rationalize all these numbers
if a designer wants to make a button a
bit smaller we can do that we can use
the tiny modifier and these are all
based around simple rules that we
actually set up in the first decision we
made the first decision we made about
this build can underpin the entire UI
now the reason designers dislike me is
this is a very very methodological
methyl I won't try and sell up word it's
a very sort of sort of clinical approach
to design it's hard to tell the design
of it I'm gonna distill your design down
to numbers it's really hard thing to get
across to them that well you might have
designed this because it looked right
but I want to change it because the
numbers work and I can trust these
numbers now and and it doesn't always
work isn't always work correctly and
they don't always appreciate that and
it's something that I have to solve I
have to live with but if we can distill
things incurred down to numbers and
rules we can have much more confidence
in growing occurred that's because we
know what to spin out from where so
typography is another really a really
sort of important thing here again this
is kind of a piggybacking the work that
Nicole's been doing or has done so we've
got our fifth 16 pixel based font size
and also can we've got a read more link
that's one pixel smaller than that and
we've got a caption that's one pixel
larger here we've got skirt for
normalization why we got this slight
departure users probably weren't nervous
that one pixel difference so why even
have it in the first place we can
piggyback here Kamel elements we've
already got here as one through to your
headings one to six and body copy and
small print that's already eight
different sizes of thumb out of the box
we shouldn't really add to that if we
can avoid adding to that unnecessarily
then we really should so your body copy
is your default I always really get sort
of concerned when I see people setting
font sizes on paragraphs or on lists
because if you set that higher up if you
sell on the hit from element that will
trickle down anyway and again this is
just micro optimizations to cut bits out
of a code base you shouldn't need a font
size on a paragraph because that should
be given by something that's happened
we're further at the Dom it's a body
copy is the default the thing you put on
the HML element the the font size you
give that should trickle down to
everything and headings in small print
are the kind of exceptions and there
will be other exceptions you might want
a big call to action that needs to be
huge you know you can you can bend the
rules but if you stick to as many as you
come you're going to find it on the come
on rational and say incurred this yeah
so this is this is how it kind of looks
you could sort if you were to do a blog
for example I'm just a real text heavy
site that was mainly for reading that
should be our entire site's typography
sorted you shouldn't really need any
but if you do this is something again
from Nicole sort of a double stranded
heading hierarchy we can normalize an
abstract any other font sizes we need
into this kind of thing so we can cross
over h4 looks like a hitch one and this
is all part of normalizing and
rationalizing and abstracting designs
for the sake of our code quality I've
got some real quick real life examples
then real quick so the last that I built
was n skype.com it's a mobile specific
site for a sky's biggest and most
profitable online property really cool
product to work on we had this now I was
concerned about this I don't know if you
can see this this blue grid of nine
icons can you see like the blue divider
lines that split the icons apart from
each other I've kind of pulled it out
into this more stark example so the
designer said well between each icon we
want less grid and this grid has to fade
out from dark blue to light blue now we
could probably build this we could use
some pseudo elements and CSS gradients
or we could have used images like
background images but that's actually
requests we could have best 60 for those
images the last kilobytes electricity is
a stress for the sake of these really
trivial simple looking design treatments
so ideas I went back and said well look
why don't we treat why don't we use
illusion so now I'm sort of grading the
borders out we put a real subtle
gradient on the container then nav
container and now those borders are
solid colors now we can use one pixel
solid whatever and give the illusion
that these borders sort of fade out to
nothing and they don't at all it's the
background that fades but we've managed
to save tons of CSS and using just a
single one line border rules to replace
that entire thing so if we switch back
to this I really don't think they're
able to see it but the horse racing bit
that's the lighter part of the nav and
the edges are what gets darker and all
of those borders are just solid one
pixel CSS borders nothing tricky nothing
complicated the trick is to cheat and
use illusion
there are clever sneaky things you can
do
yeah I'm gonna have to really blitz
through these number Fred another really
simple example was um you can see we had
this enough and again it's this
gradiated border a really simple design
treatment something that we could all
build again how would we build it it was
the same story we could use a background
image or base64 or CSS gradients and
pseudo elements that seems like a lot of
stuff to have to do just to satisfy this
one tiny design treatment I would hit
after use ten lines of CSS gradient to
get one border between two list items it
seems really over the top and if you
scale one across an entire site the
amount of extra curly off stuffing in
there just to make simple things happen
it seems really sort of it seems really
backward so in this time I didn't use
illusion I just changed the design
completely instead of having gradiated
borders we did this kind of a try effect
I'm sure you've seen this where you you
put two sort of similar colored borders
and it creates like a bevel effect so
now the nav looks entirely different to
what it was designed us but it still
looked good for the user won't miss that
but it's the 80/20 rule we've got
something similar we've got a divider in
there but now it takes one border left
and one border right property that's all
it took to build that instead of pseudo
elements and ten lines of prefixed CSS
gradients so they're kind of moral is if
something seems unreasonably difficult
to build then don't build it if you look
at something trivially sort of a quite
quite a simple treatment and you think
it feels a bit hacky then stop
seek alternatives and rationalize and
normalize and alter the designs don't
write bad code just to keep the design
team happy the code base is what you
have to look after first and foremost if
speak to the designers but don't just go
and do it but rationalize and pare
things back and really really change
designs
to sort of suit the code quality take
the easy route I kind of I'm very
unashamed with the fact that I'm a lazy
developer and everyone should be there's
no point causing yourself work showing
off doing convoluted of the top things
for the sake of you know like you know
for keeping designers happy keep
everything as simple as possible so yeah
MDOT sky back on the last sort of
examples I showed you this is the most
brutal I've ever gone with sort of
rationalizing designs are worked very
closely with a designer at sky and it
was fantastic it was surgically
experienced for for the birth of us it's
the most pared back design we have ever
built it's the most brutal post about
thing I've ever worked on
it looks fantastic all the users love it
we get lots of great feedback but the
best feedback we get every single time
is how fast this site is we've got a
suite of performance engineers who work
on the tech stack but I am the front-end
performance guy and I get great pride
out thinking that me and the designers
have built a site where the users can't
wait to tell us how fast it is we
constantly get told that we are faster
than all our competitors and it's all
down to us of rationalizing and
normalizing these designs just to keep
code bases tiny really I'm gonna rush
through this now then see if we don't
deliver designs users don't interact
with PSD interact with web sites so the
curd quality should become our foremost
concern make compromises for the sake of
the build for it discuss things with
your team and and really work on the
best solution to deliver a product
rather than a design and stick as many
rules as you can and just be lazy and
cheat and that's me with one minute left
so thank you all for listening thank you
very much
you
you